muskoxen mail stand five feet at the
shoulder and weigh a massive 800 pounds
aside from polar bears they are the
largest animals that roam the Arctic
tundra but even they are vulnerable to
predators a pack of arctic wolves
catches the herd set
the musk oxen scrambled to form a
defensive ring the adults equipped with
long hooked horns are more than a match
for the war but it's not the adults the
wolves are after the herd panics and
runs it is a fatal mistake their lines
broken they cannot protect their young
the Wolves separate out a cap though
it's as large as the alpha male wolf the
calf is still one against mental without
the help of the turn the calf eventually
succumbs to attack a few days later the
wolf pack is on the hunt again their
quarry as before our musk oxen the oxen
try to run away but this time the adults
stick close to their calf built for the
frigid arctic musk oxen will actually
overheat if they run for too long they
were all around to face off against
their pursuers the wolves try again to
make them run
but the attempts are half-hearted at
best and the oxen stand their ground
opting for easier targets the wolves
move on leaving the tundra free for the
musk oxen to roam again